D says Bella Charlie and Carter are any
of you guys famous in love or just
famous and single Oh smartly word it
there
oh um single like a Pringle which
doesn't really make sense because
they're like in a stack of other
Pringles so I don't know why that's not
in space but yeah just chillin guys
chillin oh yeah I mean Ellen Cheyenne
this pains me to ask you this what
happened with Scott Disick and how old
were you when you met and how old was I
times I haven't known for that long I've
been the same age we're chill we're
chilling we're friends
we're COO um I literally just saw him so
yeah like it's all chill um I don't know
what answer you want and you're not
getting to this show really shows the
hardships and the challenges of dating
and being famous so is that something
you guys have all struggled with or what
is the biggest there's weird I mean not
for me but but like just it's just weird
- I mean Bell is my friend and then you
see things like photos people are saying
things to me I'm like I don't know and I
you don't know but you know we see
pictures I know it's just a strange
existence I was that one it really is
weird it's it's it's hard because the
paparazzi literally they know where I
live so they literally I cannot leave
the house without a photo and it's like
most of the time I'm just chilling I'm
just hanging out like I'm not dating
anybody yeah if I want to just like go
and hang out was like I should be
allowed to do that but of course as soon
as I step outside of my house I have to
take that commitment of being like oh
god what what are people are gonna say
who's gonna write this about and it's
just like that makes you so unhappy
thing that kind of stuff if you have to
think about doing that before every
single time you hang out with anybody
guy or girl like that
is so difficult like you just be like
you know I forget it okay like I don't
want to do any of this but it's hard
yeah well do you wish it would all go
away ever have you ever gotten to that
point I mean I feel like with anything
it's like everything has its ups and
downs so like there's so many great
things about like that side of it in the
way that it's like somebody will see a
paparazzi photo of me we're like you
know I have no makeup on my skin looks a
mess and some girl then say to me hey by
the way the fact that you go out with
your acne and like you don't wear makeup
like that makes me so happy because now
I feel like I can do that that is
amazing
like that is the part that you strive
for every day and then there's the
downside of everybody being like oh my
god what's she doing but it's all just
like whatever chilling you know
you